hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the mortuary assistant
where you get to assist
in the
proceduring the
processing it was just
really weird so some stuff fell over
that's not a big deal no i know it
wasn't even my fault but he sent me home
right after that
i'm just really worried he was supposed
to finalize my stuff today
and he said he would right
yeah
so
that's a good thing
yeah
it just didn't feel like he meant it
like
he just said it to get me out of the
building
wait a sec i have another call
hello hey rebecca it's raymond oh hi mr
delver look if i did anything wrong
today just no no uh i wanted to
apologize
you've done a fantastic job i'm just not
feeling too well
that's uh actually why i'm calling
i know it's late but we just got three
new cadavers and no one else can make it
in right now
i was hoping you could come in and take
care of them well yeah
are you sure i mean of course
excellent
you're doing me a huge favor
i took care of the rest of your
onboarding we're all set
and your new badge is in your personal
belongings drawer in the back room
that's great thank you i'm on my way
right now i hope you feel better
thanks again
i'll see you tomorrow
bye or will you holy that was him
he signed me on he needs me to come in
tonight
see
i told you it was fine that's fine
congratulations all fine thanks
i have to go like right now i'll talk to
you later
okay bye i'm gonna go cut open some
cadavers
hell yeah
it's my dream
i'm guessing it is my dream because this
is kind of my job
all right
well that was nice
coffee
coffee coffee coffee
coffee coffee coffee coffee
coffee
what does it say this product
creates
mud water when
heated and made wet it doesn't taste
very good and it produces a helpful
burst of energy but it produces that
becomes harder and harder to obtain the
more you drink it chase that dragon
you'll never
go
radio nuts because we play the same song
because
it's all we have the budget for
thank you where's my keys i gotta find
pocket in the fridge is it the happy
tofu
mozzarella
at least there's some food in here wolf
theo wolfos there's food in here
i love that they went through the detail
of making all the things
actually
okay all right what have we got
silverware no plates nah
bop hots nah
oh kuos it supposedly doesn't have bees
in it but they keep putting it on the
box that it's got bees in it okay it's a
cereal that does not have bees in it
long ago daniel
donald mcmullan hatched one simple idea
what if bees were in cereal an idea that
would not be accepted today or even in
mcmulleman's time didn't stop him from
innovation not long after okuos were
born with the original recipe of mashed
bees and the well-known slogan it's got
bees in it after multiple recalls
spanning multiple decades the okuo
formula has been adjusted to fit our
changing times we are proud to say that
okuo certainly does not contain bees
however we hold on to our founding
slogan to remind us of our rich past
well that's good to know moth bombs
insanely sweet this product contains
chemicals known in every state to cause
different kinds of bowel
destruction
it can because i've had them they're not
fun and no it's not because i wasn't
chewing my food properly it's not don't
think that it was if you don't know what
i'm talking about you haven't been
listening to distractible
kind of tastes like leaves with sticks
luna bits
our goal is to make the most wholesome
cereal just like grandma used to make
400 years ago we harvest the fallen
leaves of our oak trees deep in the fall
months and dry them by hand to
achieve that crunch we all love after
removing the sticks we grind our leaves
then add the sticks back in
the process ensures the same great
natural bite enjoyed by humans and
horses alike
that's great i love that um but keys are
nowhere to be found
i can't find my keys oh
what happened what am i looking am i
inside myself
what
okay whatever
wow this oh
he's the apartment car and front door of
river fields there we go
okay away i go then thank you i found my
keys but i ran into all the good stuff
in the apartment too so that's a bonus
i made it
i think
hello
it's me
cup
coffee
closed door nah leave it open
all right um all right i guess i'll head
to the back and get started
sure i'll do just that mr delver's
business card deceased care and service
recommendation okay milford that's where
i'm from but that's melford connecticut
so it's a
lesser milford a clipboard used for
forms and keeping track of mortuary
tasks at least i can keep track of
things yep
uh-huh
oh
those fuses i have a funny feeling i'm
gonna need those
he
and bombing room key key to the
embalming room hall
oh you can attempt to use items at any
time access quick inventory and choose
the item you wish to use most but not
all places where items can be found will
cause them
cause the use item icon to appear good
to know
rebecca thank you for coming in on such
short notice the body currently in the
embalming room is done so please return
it to cold storage and get started on
the next one i've left the key to the
embalming room in the top drawer or the
front desk p.s don't forget your
clipboard
all right
okay
oh i think when i'm done i pop it in
this bad boy and that says to mr denver
i'll be done
oh that's a
that's not fun all right
cool
matches that'll be useful when the power
eventually goes out
hello
i need to poop i can't see my face oh
hi
oh
oh a cleaning solution for cleaning
tanks of a ball of embalming machines i
already have one of those i do
i definitely do um
how about i put this oh
smaller items or oh in my pockets i
thought that was saying that was in my
pocket how do i do a quick quick
match i can't use that here
we'll try you can use them anywhere
hello
ah
drizzly
oh hey bud how you doing good to see you
um
i've heard that you were done so
[Music]
oh i think i actually played like an
early version this seems familiar i
remember playing something about doing
stuff like this maybe this is an
expanded version of that
right click the record system icon to
open the program match the sections on
your clipboard to the corresponding
sections on the computer once all
findings have been entered into the
system click submit to print out the
embalming records and file the records
up front to begin in the embalming
okay
oh
night shift code i don't know what that
is okay so i don't have anything for
this dude
but it did say that he was already
processed so i'm not 100 sure if i need
to do anything
oh god
ah an old key
excellent he won't need it
if he needed it he wouldn't have left it
here now i'm like obsessed with trying
everything
setting needles all right
needle injector wiring the jaw of the
disease shut great didn't know that was
a step
use for injecting cavity fluid directly
into organs great
oh
ah for grasping and compressing an
artery great
whoa
great
i can have as many of these as i can't
hold anything else i can't hold anything
else or
can i
nice can't hold anything else oh
cavity oh just a tub
i guess it's efficient
oh my new work badge rebecca
dwens owens owens would make a lot more
sense
ah
mr delver don't look so uh
settling he looks unsettling
all right cool good great
well time to wheel you back in
hi
it's a customer
hello
hi
okay
sure
i'm gonna go with sure
oh
andy roder
cordell zimmerman
rebecca owens yeah all right i'm sure
that'll come all right
time to stop faffing about
i guess i'll just get you
hey i guess we're going for a ride
don't do anything don't you do anything
you better not do anything
i'm gonna i'm gonna be not surprised at
all when this is just a completely
normal uh mortuary job and i'm just
freaking myself out i'm guessing you're
this guy
return i'm trying
oh do i gotta uh oh ah oh
ah
that seems like something important
this is this oh god
everything's fine that's exactly how
it's supposed to be
yeah
all right cool good stuff all right
let's just slap you back in there i hope
you're zimmerman because if you're not
all right oh i just goofed it
but i probably didn't okay
easy peasy how did i get my yeah
cool
hey what's up
hi how you doing adriel roader is that
who you is
i hate this
it's fine
it's totally fine
slide that back in there
all right let's go
miss rotor
seems like you might have been shot
[Music]
okay oh my god
hey
you that customer i heard about
hey what's up
okay you're still there
[Music]
no comment
i have no comment on that
all right let's check you out you really
got no comment about that you really got
nothing to say about that you the the
shadow that just jumped out at your face
you got nothing to say about that all
right anyway who's the clipboard all
right what do we got age 91 oh
andy andy roder taking a look
this looks fine
nothing to see here
all right um
what i'm looking at is that which looks
like it might be a wound of some kind
let's see
there's something there
i'm not seeing anything else
don't mind me
all right
step back from that well
what about the your eyes don't look good
but that might just be because you're
dead
rotate left
okay don't okay center and back don't
okay don't you move
don't you move
all right
so there was a confusion enter markings
in the computer and print report okay
that i can do
all right record system we've got
something on the left shoulder
contusion
name and
name oh making it easy on me all right
age
all right
okay
up front a packet of mortuary paperwork
related to the handling of the deceased
file up front so they're available if
requested mortuary
hey
how'd you do that how'd you tuck back
there like that
very impressive but anyway i gotta go
i gotta go
um
oh
sorry
nope
[Music]
time to embalm i should not leave the
front door open but you know i just
can't see okay there we go
i figured it out good stuff hey how you
doing andy
i'm gonna embalm you mix embalming fluid
and pump
glutaraldehyde
glutaraldehyde no that's methanol but i
have that
no i don't
we got humectant
i'm guessing a humectant is part of this
oh yeah oh yeah
formaldehyde
yep
it's one of them
you
yep nope
yep yep yep yep
methanol
and
glutara aldehyde
that ain't it okay
you're definitely not it
ah ah the top shelf good stuff
grottles
i don't think so glutamine how to hide
glutaraldehyde
oh that's normal
hey
it was all good here
make it
hey hi
hey hey what are you doing
hey come back here you could learn
something all right like manners make an
incision in the carotid artery in the
jugular vein with a scalpel and forceps
clamp tubing both veins to connect the
embalming pump okay
never know what i'm seeing on the corner
of my i'm just gonna drop these real
quick i'm gonna keep one on me because i
think i need some tubing
so i'm just gonna keep that i'm going to
need two tubing i can't hold anything
else whatever
all right
scalpel i can't use that here i think i
can
i can't use it i think i can
oh
here we go three two
one okay you didn't need to do that
whoa
hi
how's it going
what's up hey peekaboo oh someone's
there
pico no i don't have anything to say
about that so i'm not gonna whoa hey how
you doing oh andy
andy roder
you're supposed to be inside all right
ah well that's a problem
yeah
not interesting
the flash of fire and ashes of flesh
will herald the coming of my house
hi oh snap
no need to tell me twice i'm coming
oh
well
no
i can't use that here
okay oh that's good
okay
well miss owens
what
they've done an increase for you so
that's 300 milligrams now let me know if
you have any questions okay
yeah
thank you
thank you very much thank you
please just
i love you
okay
oh
ten your coin this is my coin
well
nothing
[Music]
ah
i don't think i can help you pal ooh
some kind of clay disc with markings i'm
busy with this clay disc with markings
what was that about banishing demons
back to hell before
what
are you giving me instructions here
about stuff that i'm supposed to do
cause i'm not writing
you killed him no
all right well just another day at the
office for me hey how you doing
okay well time to get back to work
hey there she is hey how you doing
don't mind me just gonna real quick girl
wham
yam
that's how you do it you get right back
to work when you fall off the horse and
go into a deep spiral of your past
trauma
you get back on the horse
uh oh you know um
that is great advice
i'm just gonna grab one of these bad
boys here i'm gonna grab one of these
bad boys here cuz i got a job to do and
you need to let me do my job all right
fine
whatever then
be that as it may i ain't afraid of no
ghosts
oh you know i don't turn around
i learned my lesson after 10 years of
playing scary games i'd learned that you
just don't turn around you never turn
around you don't turn around you never
turn around for as i do no i'm not gonna
turn around that's the last thing i'm
gonna do i'll never turn around
oh see i knew it i knew i didn't need it
oh my god
you think that was scary
okay clamp tubing
you want some tubing
have some tubing
man that was my i'm good at my job
okay engage the pump let the body drain
where where is it draining to ah
whatever
oh there
that's where it's draining
[Applause]
all right that was loud um
john another job well done step uh
whatever remove the tubes and close the
incision you got it
easy peasy
oink yoink
like it never happened
all right fill the empty iv reservoir
bag with cavity fluid then insert troker
into the abdominal cavity i remember
there being yeah here we go
flex bag all right
splat
blam
all right i remember there being a view
this is what i need
all right let's slam
fill the body cavities insert the
trucker until it stops to begin the flow
of embalming fluid once that cavity is
full pull the trucker back rotated and
reinsert at a new angle until the
reservoir bag is empty
i'm doing it
i don't need i don't know
i'm assuming those noises are happening
that are supposed to be happening
not gonna pay attention to it
who's
it's a little drafty in here so drafty
the draft
whips through this place i don't call
this the windy city for nothing
all right
tries again
now that i'm not disturbed
[Music]
i'm just going to go ahead and assume
that nothing's going to happen when i'm
done with this
why would anything
won't anything happen
i mean a job well done that's what's
going to happen a high five for my boss
all right pour pump cleaner into the
embalming pump to clean it
pretty self-explanatory
paint cleaner
wham
all right job well done
all right let's get you back uh
home
whoa
all right
well that was a fun
the door is open the four seals have
marked my coming the halls of satan echo
my reader
i am here
yeah i'm here too
well you're not here anymore
not even one side
can my name be so far from me oh was i
supposed to be doing something
was i supposed to be like
was i supposed to be hunting for
something
ah i suffer
i am
[Music]
that's great oh no
no don't do that
oh
ah i knew it was coming i knew it was
coming
all right
i'm guessing that somewhere along the
way there was probably something that i
could have done but that was very good
but let me see
because i'm wondering i'm wondering if
there's actually like they're talking
about seals and sigils there i'm
wondering if there's actually something
there that i can find that i might have
messed up a little bit
you know what i mean you know what i'm
talking about do you know what me mean
you understand what i'm saying
you get what i'm talking about you know
what i'm talking about
you know what i'm slinging do you know
i'm swizzling
do you know cause i do
damn no save all right well that's why
they had a skip in the beginning i'm
betting that's why they had a skip in
the beginning because if they didn't
have a skip in the beginning then i
would suggest they didn't think that
people would be coming back but i
skipped you i oh my keys are not there
really oh sure
you make me look all over this place for
my keys and then ah that's why i
couldn't find him you made me think i
was stupid
grandma
well that sure looks like uh mrs
what's her name
uh who's he what oh my keys they're in a
different place
replayability
i like that are my keys i just had my
keys
what i
i literally just picked up my keys you
oh wait no here they are
there we go it was a lie before
apparently
a replayability that tells me something
there was probably a sigil in my house
[Music]
all right i guess i'll head to the back
and get started there's got to be
something else because i had these fuses
what were the fuses for right
and there was that old key
hmm
an old key
for mr delver and then there was that
code
small notebook rebecca you weren't
supposed to find this yet but i suppose
you found my key you simply aren't ready
for this work i can't let you live what
i live not yet maybe in the spring
coming spring 20. oh
but the name sigils
oh
i'm ready boss boss
boss i'm ready
you tell me that there's no way to find
this guy's name
you telling me
is you telling me i bet there's a way
something here spring 20 22 huh what
about 202 2
uh-huh
2022 enter how about zero zero
two
seven oh two bam okay now does this mean
that it's actually not available or is
that just trying to throw me off
i bet it's trying to throw me off
hey faulty power
oh
what if i
yeah what if i okay what if there's
something already in here
i'm a genius
ashes remain scraped from the retort
uh-huh i can't use that here
i can't use it there must be a way to
sift through the remains i would guess
i'm just guessing
what if it's like what if i could put
something in with the embalming like i
gotta fuss up this body you know
like if i put the ashes in there but the
asses are like
supposed to be for something
you know what i mean
just don't tell anybody i'm going to
look up some i'm going to try to look it
up see if i'm wasting my time
[Music]
yeah i'm less
i'm less hopeful that there's something
now
i kind of looked around to see if there
was even like a clue to see if i was
wasting my time
maybe i was
hello i don't remember seeing anything
maybe i am maybe i'm not i don't know
what if i just go ahead and put the
ashes in here
all right fine fine
i'm gonna leave it at this well thank
you everybody so much for watching this
is the demo to the mortuary assistant i
will definitely be playing this when the
full game comes out and maybe i'm
missing something so let me know down in
the comments below you can play this
game for yourself right in the
description thank you check out other
scary games that i played also linked in
the description or the scary games
playlist of which there are hundreds
thank you again and as always i will see
you
in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]